E aí
[Música]
Oi boa tarde imaginei que estão perante
uma orquestra mas estão de olhos
fechados e nisto entrou violino
Oi e um pouco mais à frente e entrou
violoncelo
E aí
e eu tenho certeza que mesmo de olhos
fechados vocês não consegui distinguir
os dois instrumentos e Tem a certeza
porque ouvir o hino um instrumento muito
mais Pequenino vai ter um som mais agudo
e quanto que o violoncelo instrumentos a
maior vai ter um som mais grave e também
sobre os dizer que as estrelas são
autênticos e Instrumentos Musicais
é na realidade não só elas são
instrumentos musicais como os astrónomos
utilizam de facto a sua música para
saber e um bocadinho mais acerca delas
na realidade eles utilizam essa música
para ver aquilo que a partir da parceria
invisível ou seja para conseguirem
ultrapassar essa barreira que é
superfície aparentemente alpaca de uma
estrela e ver diretamente do seu
interior mas antes eu os falar um
bocadinho mais acerca disto eu gostaria
de lembrar que eu estou aqui a falar e
na realidade que eu estou a fazer é
Perturbar um meio eu estou a perturbar o
ar aqui a minha volta e essas pequenas
perturbações as expansões e contrações
do ar estão a propagar e é por isso que
aquilo que eu estou a dizer chega aos
ouvidos de quem está ouvir eu penso nós
imaginarmos que as estrelas são grandes
gigantes gasosas e que no seu interior
também a turbulência conseguimos
perceber imediatamente que no interior
das Estrelas é possível gerar em sondas
de som
o som da Samsung se vão propagar e
interferir entre si para gerar e aquilo
que nós chamamos as frequências que
próprias que no fundo são as notas que
compõem a música das estrelas mas
efetivamente essa música se por um lado
nos faz a nossa astrônomos uma forma
atentar quanto romântica dizer que são
as estrelas são instrumentos musicais e
até a de alguma forma especiais porque
são esféricos e por simples e por que
não precisa um músico para as trocares
oferecem-nos a sua música também é
verdade que nem função rosas porque
efetivamente o o som produzido pelas
estrelas à cabo que ficar confinado no
seu interior e fica confinado no seu
interior porque o som não se propaga No
vazio e aquilo que nos separa das
Estrelas é essencialmente espaço vazio e
pertence nós queremos utilizar o som das
Estrelas Como eu disse para
compreendermos
a mãe já acerca delas nós temos que
ultrapassar esta limitação e podemos
ultrapassá-la porque se nós não ouvimos
a música proibida para as estrelas nós
podemos certamente ver essa música e
podemos ver essa música por também ela
se expandem contraia E à medida que a
superfície da estrela se expande e
contrai o seu brilho vai variar um
bocadinho um quase nada ao longo do
tempo e essas pequeníssimas variações
podem ser detectadas os nossos por
satélites que estão para lá da atmosfera
terrestre Como por exemplo o satélite
que é por da Nasa que conseguiu já desta
forma observar a música em milhares de
estrelas diferentes
É mas não não é esta a única forma que
nós conseguimos ver a música das
Estrelas nós efetivamente também
Conseguimos ver a música das Estrelas a
partir do seu movimento partir daquilo
que nós chamamos o efeito de Doppler
porque se nós pensarmos na luz como
chega das Estrelas é só os pode ser
decomposta no espectro eletromagnético e
esse espeto vai ter a riscas escuras
essas riscas escuras são causadas por
absorção da luz em frequências muito
particulares por elementos químicos que
estão na atmosfera da estrela e essas
riscas tem nos devia porque à medida que
a superfície da estrela expande e
contrai dessa forma se aproxima E afasta
de nós também essas riscas vão mexer
para o azul e para o vermelho do
espectro e portanto também a partir
dessas riscas nós do movimento essas
riscos um espectro nós fomos capazes de
caráter
e a música das estrelas e
é mas efetivamente se a ideia de ver o
som posso é relativamente nova a ideia
de ver com o som certamente que não é e
nós sabemos porque a natureza não faz em
particular Os Nós temos que os morcegos
conseguem mapear as cavidades escuras
onde se movem e detectar as suas presas
a partir do Eco e também nós fazemos em
quando em ambiente hospitalar Fazemos
uma ecografia e portanto o desafio que
astronomia em particular as estrelas nos
coloca e de facto o sermos capazes de
ver com o som em estrelas que são corpos
que estão muito distantes ou seja nós
não podemos experimentar com as estrelas
nós não podemos chegar a uma estrela e
emite som para dentro da estrela e
depois por um receptor a superfície para
receber o eco e dessa forma Me Up
se não nós temos efetivamente que nos
bastar com aquilo que ela nos oferece
é mas eu gostaria de voltar a ideia do
violino e violoncelo inicial para vos
dizer que efetivamente a propriedade
mais básica de uma estrela que nós
conseguimos caracterizar a partir da
música das Estrelas é o seu tamanho
é isso todos lembramos que as estrelas
são corpos ou também de Gigantes nós
imediatamente percebemos que o som que
elas produzem a ser um som extremamente
grave e na realidade ele é tão grave que
mesmo que se são conseguir chegar até
nós nós já sabemos que isso não é
possível mas mesmo conseguir chegar até
nós nós Nunca seremos capazes de ouvir
com os nossos ouvidos e portanto sempre
quiser mostrar um exemplo do som
produzido por uma estrela o que vai
acontecer na realidade é que eu vou ter
que fazer um truque eu vou ter que pegar
no Sumo da estrela tal como e ele é
caracterizada a partir dos nossos
instrumentos e transpor e a solução para
a Gama do audível tantas frequências
programa do audível E foi exatamente
isso que se fez com quatro estrelas
observadas por satélite que Apple para
construir um concerto que eu agora vos
vou mostrar Vamos ouvir
E aí
[Risadas]
tá bom não será propriamente um concerto
de música clássica eu peço desculpa é
mais um ruído mas eu acho que é um ruído
que deixa bem claro o impacto que a
música das estrelas e com o tamanho das
Estrelas desculpem que tem na música que
elas produzem e que se nós pensarmos por
exemplo no uma estrela como o Sol é uma
estrela relativamente pequena nós
sabemos que o som que ela vai produzir
vai ser um som relativamente Agudo como
comparado com o são por exemplo
produzido por uma gigante vermelha bom
mas efetivamente o tamanho das estrelas
não é a única coisa que nós conseguimos
aprender a partir da sua música Nós
também somos capazes de aprender acerca
pormenores particulares no interior da
estrela e um exemplo muito claro disso é
o região regiões onde a estrutura da
estrela muda de uma forma adulta
efetivamente se nós pensarmos por
exemplo na energia produzida por uma
estrela nós
E aí é produzida no interior da estrela
a partir de reações nucleares Mas ela
tem que ser transportado até a
superfície onde é libertada por que a
estrela está efetivamente em equilíbrio
e se nós pensarmos que esse transporte
pode ser feito formas diferentes e em
particular a certas regiões onde esse
transporte é feito pela própria radiação
e depois outras regiões onde esse
transporte é feito por movimento do
próprio gás um bocadinho como uma panela
de água a ferver e isto porque o gás
torna demasiado opaco para a radiação
ser se o sentimento eficiente no
transporte energia nós conseguimos
imaginar que esta passagem de uma região
o ano de transporte é de um tipo para a
região onde o transporte é de outro tipo
introduz uma variação abrupta na
estrutura da estrela e o som da mesma
forma que ele quis falar convosco se me
colocar em uma barreira entre nós
repente um som fica de alguma forma
distorcido também na estrela esta região
muito de varia
e ainda vai introduzir uma assinatura
muito particular no som produzido por
estrela e nós podemos por exemplo A
partir dessa assinatura no caso do Sol
podemos dizer que aquela região de
convecção onde gastar em movimento ocupa
cerca de trinta por cento do raio da
estrela nós conseguimos efetivamente
fazer mais isso nós conseguimos ver
diretamente a dinâmica do interior de
uma estrela e Conseguimos ver a dinâmica
do interior de uma estrela que o sol não
roda de forma uniforme a sua superfície
e sabemos porque a superfície do Sol tem
manchas chamadas manchas solares são
regiões mais frias e mais escuras e que
tenta o movimento essas manchas diz-nos
que o sol no Equador roda mais depressa
do que o sol nos seus polos nós não sabe
não saberíamos tem a música do Sol o que
que acontece no seu interior e aquilo
que nós sabemos a partir da música
produzida pelo sol é que a camada mais
exterior aquela camada que eles falei de
convecção
e como na superfície de forma não
uniforme Mas como vamos foi interior do
Sol quando está aquela região onde o
transporte é feito pela radiação aí o
sol roda de uma forma perfeitamente
uniforme ou seja nós conseguimos fazer
uma autêntica ecografia a dinâmica de
uma estrela
a press santástico mas o que é que isso
nos traz o que é que nós ganhamos com tu
e quando nós fazemos uma ecografia em
ambiente hospitalar o ganho é óbvio nós
estamos a falar do bem-estar do ser
humano temos uma ecografia uma estrela e
eu encontro astrônomo enquanto cientista
enquanto entusiasta destas coisas eu
posso dizer que nós estamos haverá
física a funcionar em condições
absolutamente extremas em condições que
nós não seríamos capazes de reproduzir
no nosso laboratório E por aí nós
estamos a fazer algo de importante
estamos a ir mais além do nosso
conhecimento mas por comparação Pode
parecer pouco
bom e se calhar parece pouco porque eu
não estou pegar nesta forma certa porque
se calhar efetivamente as brigadeiro
importância daquilo que eu estou a dizer
está mais uma vez intimamente ligada às
necessidades do ser humano e em
particular essa necessidade que o ser
humano tem de compreender e até dominar
tudo o que eu falei ah e ao mesmo tempo
facinho que tenho para que o que
ultrapassa
e quando no na segunda metade do século
20 os astrónomos perceberam que podiam
ver o interior do Sol fizeram em
esforços para conseguirem por
observatórios em tudo Globo para poderem
ultrapassar alimentação dos dias e das
noites para conseguirem observar o sol
continuamente e quando umas décadas mais
tarde decidiram que queriam ver o
interior das Estrelas utilizando
exatamente a mesma técnica
a saber 1 que se o queriam fazer em
grande escala tinham que ir para o
espaço mas também perceber a outra coisa
perceber o que não conseguiam fazer
sozinhos que precisavam se juntar a
outros para astrônomos aqueles que andam
à procura de planetas em torno de outras
estrelas e que também precisam do mesmo
tipo de dados de observação mas que ao
mesmo tempo também Estão interessados em
caracterizar as estrelas porque afinal
de contas as estrelas são o elemento
agregador de qualquer sistema planetário
perguntaram sem cirurgia com as outras
planos para conseguirem cumprir o seu
objetivo na realidade a maior parte
daquilo que eu vos mostrei hoje só foi
possível porque muitas centenas de
astrônomos em dezenas de países
diferentes se juntaram em grandes
consórcios para obterem os dados que
eram necessários para ver o interior das
estrelas e em particular o interior de
nosso sol e é por isso que eu gosto de
pensar que as
É por esses grandes Desafios que nos
coloca em um bom exemplo dessa
capacidade que o homem também tem quando
quer se juntar aos outros de ultrapassar
fronteiras e juntar-se aos outros em
busca de um objetivo comum e é assim
porque o ser humano é curioso
em todo o homem é curioso a curiosidade
humana essa necessidade que nós temos de
sistematicamente pôr à prova os nossos
limites e ver mais além compreender mais
além e se a curiosidade é absolutamente
transversal é transformar as nações é
transversal as culturas e é transversal
ao tempo
Oi E a propósito disso eu não gostaria
de acabar sem vos falar um grande
astrônomo o ser é de que viveu entre o
século o final do século 19 e primeira
metade do século 20 que em 1926 há quase
cem anos num dos livros que ditou a
constituição interna das Estrelas dizia
o seguinte a primeira vista dir-se-ia
que o interior do Sol e das outras
estrelas que está menos acessível a
investigação do que qualquer outra
região do universo e um bocadinho mais
adiante perguntava instrumento
conseguirá atravessar a superfície de
uma estrela e revelar as condições no
seu interior
e isto perguntou Wellinton há quase 100
anos hoje nós temos a resposta a esta
pergunta nós sabemos que a resposta e as
instrumento que é dentro escada é a
música que nos permite ultrapassar a
superfície de uma estrela e ver o seu
interior mas sem anos volvidos nós
sabemos isso porque nunca deixamos de
ser curiosos
e é que estão para se perguntar o que
saberemos daqui a mais tem obrigada
E aí
[Música]